durant cette épidémie il faut absolument
d'abord limiter les visites au maximum
je vais demander à tous nos concitoyens
d'avoir cet esprit de responsabilité de
faire ce sacrifice
je sais que c'est parfois un crève coeur
mais il faut au maximum
évitez de visiter nos anciens quand les
aînés sont dans des situations qui le
justifie avec l'accord des équipes
médicales en prenant toutes les
précautions
les visites peuvent se maintenir mais il
faut essayer au maximum de limiter ses
visites strict nécessaire
essayer au maximum que les plus jeunes
ne fasse pas partie de ces visites parce
que comme on le sait aujourd'hui ils
transmettent beaucoup le virus ça c'est
très important c'est le premier point de
discipline et pendant la crise il faut
le faire je sais que c'est dur et donc
il faut essayer de communiquer
différemment c'est pour protéger